نعم هذه هي صوره خاصه للعربيه
لاستعداد طائره الاولى من الجسر الجوي
السعودي وهي طائره الاولى بالنسبه
المغادره من مطار الملك خالد الدولي الى
مطار حلب طبعا وتحمل على متنها اكثر من 32
طن من المواد الاغاثيه والمستلزمات الطبيه
وكذلك خيام وبطانيات رئيس فريق الجهود
المشتركه الاستاذ فالح بن دهيمان تحدث
للعربيه وهو رئيس فريق الجهود المشتركه
المتدربي الزلزال تحدث ان التنسيق بالنسبه
لهذه الرحله جاءت بعد تنسيق مع الجهات
المعنيه الانسانيه داخل سوريا وان ايضا
هناك احتياجات وفرتها السعوديه
ارسلتها الجهات المعنيه ما هي ما هي هذه
الاحتياجات المستلزمات الطريه نعم ما هي
هذه الاحتياجات
التي تقلع فيها الطائره الاولى المتجهه من
مطار الملك خالد الدولي الى مطار حلب وهي
الطائره الثامنه بالنسبه للجسر الجوي
السعودي
لاغاثه متضررين الزلزال طبعا نعود مره
اخرى الاحتياجات التي تحدث بها رئيس فريق
الجهود المشتركه الاستاذ فالح بن دهيمان
والتي استقبلتها السعوديه بالنسبه بعد رفع
احتياجات من قبل الجهات المعنيه الانسانيه
داخل سوريا مثل حليب الاطفال
والمستلزمات الطبيه وايضا بعض الاحتياجات
للاحفاظ على الدم مثل ثلاجات لبنك الدم
وبعض الاجهزه الكهربائيه طبعا يتم كنا
نسال الرئيس الفريق الجهود المشتركه كيف
سوف يتم توزيع هذه
الاغاثه على المتضررين وهل سوف تشمل كافه
المناطق المتضرره ام هناك مناطق معينه
تحدثها ان هناك تنسيق مع جهات معنيه
للهلال الاحمر السوري وسوف يتم توزيع هذه
الاغاثه على كافه المناطق او المتضررين من
جراء هذا الزلزال ايضا تحدث للعربيه ان
هناك طائرتين سوف تقرعان في اليومين
القادمين الثانيه قد تكون في نفس في نفس
هذا التوقيت من يوم غد
والثالثه سوف يتبعها
بيوم اضافه الى ان ايضا الجسر الجوي مستمر
متى ما رفعت الجهات المعنيه الانسانيه
داخل سوريا الاحتياجات التي يحتاجها
المتضرر من جراء هذا الزلزال ايضا كنا
نساله عن ما اذا كانت السعوديه سوف تقوم
باعمال الانسانيه اخرى خاصه في البناء
التحتيه لمتضرر تحدث ان
يعتبر الجهود او الفريق المشترك للجهود او
اعانه واغاثه متضررين الزلزال هي فقط
الجهود الانسانيه وليس من اختصاص
في دعم البناء التحتيه او ما شابه ذلك
عموما ان هذه الطائره سوف تصل بعد اربع
ساعات من الان سوف تصل الى سوف يستقبلها
الجمعيه الهلال الاحمر السوري وايضا سوف
نوافيكم بالتفاصيل ما اذا كانت استطعنا
الوصول اخرى
عمليه التوزيع ونحن سنتابع معك كل
التفاصيل المرتبطه بهذا الجسر الجوي
المفتوح الان بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه جراء هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب
الاراضي التركيه والاراضي السوريه شكرا
جزيلا لك هاني الصوفيا وان كنت متابع
لاقلاع الطائره الثامنه من هذا